こんにちははじめしゃちょーです今日は
ですね
ずーっとやりたかったんですけどもコロナ
とかがあってなかなかできなかったです
けどもようやく本日
実現可能になりました
皆さんも気になってる方多いと思います
はじめしゃちょーのイントネーション挑戦
[音楽]
永遠の謎というわけで皆さんも気になっ
てると思いますし僕も気になっています
いろんな人に聞かれますはじめしゃちょー
の発音イントネーションは何が正しいのか
僕もわかりませんトミさん今日よろしくお
願いしますお願いします
ルビーさんはちなみにはじめしゃちょーっ
ていう時どう発音されます
僕はですねはじめしゃちょーです
消費者庁のタイプですね
非常に難しくてもう本当にいろんな人が
いろんな発音しててどのイントネーション
が正しいのか正直わからないんですし僕も
何でもいいんですよどうでもいいんです
ただいろんな方に本当に質問されてどう
言えばいいのか正しいのかって言われても
答えられないので今回これを大衆の皆様
国民の皆様に直接お聞きして何が正しいの
かを皆様自身に決めていただきたいと思っ
ております今あのマネージャーさんの
ロビーさんがおっしゃったようにロビさん
はじめしゃちょーですよねはじめしゃ
ちょーです僕ははじめしゃちょーなんです
よあとよくあるのははじめしゃちょーって
いう多分なんでこの違いが起きるかって
いうとはじめしゃちょーって僕言うんです
けどもそれも正しいな
正しくないですからね
例えばですよはじめしゃちょーのはじめが
田中だったとするじゃないですか田中社長
って言わないと思うんですよはじめ社長は
はじめと社長の
初めの方に力を置いている言い方人の名前
を呼ぶのに近い方はじめしゃちょーは僕の
ことをほんと役職だと思ってるタイプです
ねなるほど
田中部長と一緒みたいな感じですよ完全に
僕をその会社の一員として見てる言い方で
今ロビンさんがおっしゃってたはじめしゃ
ちょーっていう方はもう僕のこと消費者庁
と勘違いしてる
部長とか社長っていうよく使われる言葉と
初めてを人の名前が合体してめちゃくちゃ
ややこしい芸名みたいになってると思うの
で今回その発音何が正しいのかを今日
こちら渋谷の交差点スクランブル交差点に
来ております
今までにまともにやったことのないあの
街頭インタビューを今日私
自らちょっと天気悪いので人をそんなに
多くなさそうなのでそして平日
昼間何とかできないかなと思ってちょっと
いろんな人に僕のイントネーション聞いて
みたいと思いますというわけで今回なんと
ですねちょっとテレビぽくしたいなと思っ
てフジテレビさんでご協力いただいてあの
ちゃんとしたフリップ準備させていただき
ましたこれすごいですよね
テレビで見るような感じのフリップで
ほんとにはじめしゃちょーの
イントネーション皆さんどう呼びます
かっていうのを聞いて本当これは分かり
やすいですよねはじめ社長最初だけ上がる
やつはじめ社長が最初だけ下がるやつ
はじめしゃちょーもう1つはじめしゃ
ちょー消費者の方ですねおそらくこの3つ
に分類されるかなと思ってどう発音するの
かを色んな人に聞いてシール貼ってって
もらって一番多いやつが
僕の正しい発音になります僕も今後その
発音に直させていただきます
[音楽]
というわけであのーそもそも僕がコミュ障
なので
街ヒットに話しかけられるかどうかから
始まると思います
ロビンさんの予想はどれですかはじめしゃ
ちょーだとかあこれですか
僕もそう思いますというわけでいろんな人
に聞いていきたいと思います頑張ります
渋谷でございます
すごいなぁ
東京雨降ってるからほんと人は少ないです
ね
ロビーさんはよく渋谷に来られるんで僕来
ないですね
意外と実家が近いんですけど全然来ない
絶対どこですか
あの人
俺知ってる
俺フォローしてるんですよ
おはようお兄ちゃん
勇気ね
誰かいける
こんにちはこんにちはこんにちははじめ
しゃちょーって知ってますか
イントネーションが何が正しいのかわかん
なくて皆さんに聞いてるんですけどもどう
発音します
もう1回ですはじめしゃちょーはじめしゃ
ちょー
です
まだあります
こんにちはどこから来ましたか千葉県から
来ました
YouTubeは結構見ました
ありがとうございます
はじめしゃちょーはじめしゃちょー
ちょっと高い下がりますありがとう
[音楽]
ございましたご覧ください結構人が集まっ
てきました
ここまで行くと呼んだら来てくれるんじゃ
ないかって
誰かインタビューしていいですか
うわめっちゃありがとうお願いします
あなたははじめしゃちょー知ってますか
さっき見てたありがとうそれはありがとう
皆さんねお聞きしてるんですけど
僕の名前どうやって
発音しますか
この中だとこれだよね
俺もねこっちなんだよ
勝手に一緒だねありがとう
こんにちは
どこから来ました
使うことをお聞きするんですけどあの
YouTuberのはじめしゃちょー
してるんですけども俺
の方だって自分で何が正しいのか
聞いてるんですけどもどれですか
こんにちは
イケメンだね
マジでありがとう
あいつさあはじめしゃちょーってさどう
読んでる呼ぶ時
僕はじめましたはじめしゃちょー最初に
別れたいそうなんだよありがとういい
感じだねまだわかんないですどんどん聞い
ていきたいと思いますこんにちは
YouTuberのはじめしゃちょーって
分かりますか
チャンネル登録してるもう
初期から知ってますありがとうございます
知ってるということでちょっとしてみたい
んですけども1回名前を言ってみてもらっ
ていいですか
はじめしゃちょーこっちだやっぱこっちな
のか2人のおかげで結構こっち説濃厚に
なってきたわこんにちはどこから来ますか
大学から来たんだいぶ幅広いけど
ちょっとご飯食べたい
女の子に聞きたいんですけども
知ってます
あいつの名前を1回言ってみてもらっても
いいですか
みたいな初めて
コンスタントいただきましたありがとう
ございます色々流行ってます一番
面白
い分かってる子がいましたこんにちは
ちょっと今どこから来たんですか
東京です
けどもあのいるじゃん慎重でけ
変なあのはじめしゃちょー
YouTuber
知ってます
[音楽]
あの人の名前を1回ちょっと言ってみて
もらっていいですかはじめしゃちょー
説明社長こっちかはじめしゃちょーはじめ
しゃちょー2人分かりましたこれ最近動画
見てもらった見てないです見てないです
こんにちはどこから来たの
東京に2人でも東京に住んでるんだじゃあ
そんな2人はYouTubeとかよく見る
かな
今日朝見たの
いい子発見
に行きたい
んですけどね
2人は俺の名前どう発動しますか
はじめしゃちょー
違いましたね今2人違いましたねちょっと
場所を変えてみましょうかハチ公だ噂の
これが噂の8校前ですか
全然渋谷来ないからマジで新鮮こんにちは
誰かわかりますかはじめしゃちょーそう
ですこんにちはお二人にお聞きしたいん
ですけど
僕の発音を今調べてましてどう発音しまし
た今
説明社長こっち
始め社長
こっちだ2人と
荒れてきたなまたありがとうございます
ありがとう
ございます
毎日4本ありがとう
1日
9本9本来ました
はじめしゃちょー
[音楽]
誰だこいつという心の声を知っておりまし
たこんにちはお聞きしたいんですけど
名前のイントネーションが僕自身もわから
なくなるんですよ何が正しいのか今街角
調査してるどう発音してますか
こんにちは
よかったらあの僕の名前をカメラに向かっ
て叫んでいただいてもらってせーの
あれ違った
違ってます2人は何と言いますか
ありがとう
ございますいいサンプルが取れました2人
一緒にいても違う
いやーありがとう
ございますどっちかが正しくてどっちかが
間違ってるんで決まったらその名前でお
願いしますはいというわけでだいぶ聞け
ましたね今20人以上の人に聞いてみたん
ですけれどももうちょっと聞きたいんです
けれどもちょっと最終結果僕結構楽しみな
んでここで僕はインタビューやめます
ロビーさんお願いしますちょっと待って
結果待ってみてなりたいのでこの僕が聞き
続けるとジワジワわかっちゃうんでね
聞いて
映像押さえててそれを見て
分かりました
残念なのがすごい気になってます僕は僕の
本当の
呼び方よしさんでしたじゃあ
僕は
マックでも行ってきますね
ナンパしてるみたいな
はじめしゃちょーはじめしゃちょーはじめ
しゃちょーはじめしゃちょーはじめしゃ
ちょーはじめしゃちょーはじめしゃちょー
はいというわけで街頭インタビュー終了し
ました
最初の方は全部僕がやったんですけども
途中から結果が見たくんなくて全部あの
マネージャーさんに任せて無事に集計が
終わったということで皆さんようやく誰
しもが謎でわからなかったはじめしゃ
ちょーはじめ社長はじめしゃちょー
言い方決まりますここにその結果があり
ます僕まだ見てないので見させていただき
ましたよこれが
公式ですから俺も今後自分のことはこの
呼び方でいきます僕がパッと聞いた感じ
始め社長は絶対ないのではじめしゃちょー
がです今10年の謎が明らかに行きます
緊張する
いきますはい
[音楽]
あ
結構はじめしゃちょーいるなはじめしゃ
ちょーが7票をはじめしゃちょーが21票
はじめしゃちょーが1920212
えっと
結果からいきます
んだけどはじめしゃちょーが21票初め
社長が22票はじめしゃちょーが7票と
いうことで僕の正しい発音ははじめしゃ
ちょーに決まりましたー
[音楽]
なんて発音しますか
あーもうダメです
二度とされる呼ばないでくださいはじめし
たちょうがないです今日からはじめしゃ
ちょーです僕は
これがもう結構減ってましたねやっぱり
ほぼほぼ同点なので
ぶっちゃけどっちでもいいとどっちでも
いいとは言いたいんですが1票の差で
はじめしゃちょーになってしまいましたの
でこれはもうね
多数決もそうですよ1票でもOKばそっち
が勝つということで結構
効いたなめちゃくちゃいろんな方に聞いて
これだったのでまあ誤差っちゃ誤差さ誤差
なんですけども一応わずかにこっちが
多かったかなっていう渋谷では地域とか
分かりますけどもそんなにこっちがメイン
かなっていきますねじゃあはじめしゃ
ちょーです
違和感が割れたこれは上だったんすよ
ずっとはじめしゃちょーって言ってたん
ですけど
どうするこれこんにちははじめしゃちょー
ですって言えないってことかも
でもマジでね色んな人になんかこの結果
だけ見ると正直どっちでもいいと思う僕
思うんですだって一緒じゃんほぼ誤差って
変わんないんですけどやっぱりいろんな人
に聞かれるんですよどっちなんだとあなた
の発音はどうなんだイントネーションが
分からないともうわずかでもこっちが
多かったということで今後はしばらく
はじめしゃちょーという発音で行かせて
いただきます皆様お間違いのないよう
よろしくお願いいたしますじゃあ
はじめしゃちょー次の里行きます
[音楽]